[Musique]
le sénat c'est un lieu de démocratie de
démocratie parlementaire
en tant que nous parlons de patrimoine
nous parlons de durabilité nous devons
aussi regarder qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur des murs de ce beau palais
il se passe une assemblée de 348
sénateurs qui votent la loi qui contrôle
le gouvernement qui trace des
prospectives qui fait des rapports sur
des sujets sensibles nous l'avons fait
ces deux semaines sur la sécurité à la
chasse nous allons avoir un débat début
octobre sur la situation de l'énergie
sur ce qui attend les françaises et les
français alors palais il est entretenu
par le sénat d'une manière je veux dire
exceptionnelle comme ce jardin mais
c'est aussi un lieu de la démocratie
vivante
[Musique]
j'étais très surprise quand on est
arrivé aujourd'hui on nous a dit qu'il y
avait une conférence avec le président
larcher et c'était super en fait de le
voir parler comme ça ouvertement à plein
de gens de répondre à deux questions et
d'avoir pu poser ma question aussi
c'était un moment très très fort
[Musique]
cette proximité est importante en fait
entre entre les institutions et les
citoyens donc très satisfaits en fait de
ma visite aujourd'hui au sénat
[Musique]
nous avons engagé depuis deux ans au
sénat j'allais dire la prise en compte
de la durabilité chaque sénateur qui le
souhaite peut avoir son empreinte
carbone nous allons nous engager encore
plus est naturellement comme tout les
françaises et tous les français nous
allons contribuer à la nécessaire
sobriété face à la crise énergétique qui
est aujourd'hui
notre quotidien
[Musique]